[Applause]
again America first
[Applause]
we actually have kind of a recovery in
2010 if you remember 2010 was kind of a
good year for water planning we've had
quite a lot of experience with populism
and protectionism in recent decades but
it's been experience in the developing
world largely and it's been experience
that you've had personally both Sydney
you were born in Egypt and then you had
lately Justin give me your sense of how
you see the merits and the dangers of
those kind of policies hmm
well I mean as you say in you know Egypt
had a very populist phase after the
Revolution and experimented with high
tariffs nationalization my own family
was nationalized
and lost all of their property in Egypt
and you know I personally experienced
massive down social mobility as a result
of that and you know we went from being
very well-off to to having very little
earner that's that's not an experience
that most people who talk about this
have had does that change the way you
view the distribution of wealth the ways
you inequality the way you work view
opportunity in an education well I mean
I think it makes me very sensitive to
how very well-intentioned
but very misguided policies can go
terribly wrong and it also makes me feel
very passionately about education so
when I was growing up my father used to
say to me it can take everything away
from you but they can't take away your
brain and he was completely obsessed
with us getting an education it was his
it was our ticket out for survival he
had done a PhD we started from scratch
again if he had not had that education
we would have never gotten anywhere my
concern about saying education is the
answer
it's like motherhood and apple pie you
know of course education is a good idea
but what kind of education how do you
need to change education to really help
those people who are now being left
behind
well it's interesting education is
actually one of the most important
drivers of the inequality that we're
observing in some countries and so
clearly restoring opportunities in
education for a broad swathe of society
is an important part of the solution
okay and if you're in a world where you
change careers two three four or five
times the idea that your education stops
at either high school or university
seems crazy but right now it seems that
the sort of embryonic system of lifetime
learning that's emerging is one that is
reinforcing inequalities rather than
countering them because the people who
are able to avail themselves of new
retraining tend to be people who would
higher income absolutely everybody
always points to the German success with
vocational training as a as a model but
having more of the day is that we need
success because that's built for going
into an industry as a approaches and
staying in it I'm not sure that that
even is very appropriate for a world
where you're going to completely
different have a complete different
profession in different decades of your
life well it's been successful at
sustaining a highly skilled industrial
workforce which is which is the case
when it hasn't done is in successful at
retooling work industrial workers or
other kinds of workers but I think it
provides the potential model that would
then have to be modified for older
workers
[Music]
the sentences we have at the moment of a
backlash not just against the elite but
a backlash against experts you are the
quintessential expert you need an expert
well Bank you've been the civil servant
in the UK or now a central bank oh
you're going to become an academic is
that backlash against the experts
justified well I mean first I think we
shouldn't forget what the experts gave
us you know I often think of the Monty
Python skit about you know what the
Romans ever do for us and you know what
did the experts ever do for ode well
they gave us words and sanlian yes
exactly so you know we have to remember
the huge gains that we've made in terms
of income life expectancy well that dawn
came from the culmination of human
knowledge that driven by experts having
said that I think some experts have
oversold what they what they can do and
I think a degree of modesty and humility
about what we know and what we don't
know is is necessary is there a danger
that this is just a huge echo chamber a
whole load of experts talking to each
other but nothing more yeah well there
is a real risk of that you know where we
make progress is where there's a real
genuine conflict of ideas and there's
genuine debate and you and knowledge
moves forward one manifestation of this
bubble mentality is I think the way
people talk to each other people talk
about importance of opportunity and
inclusive capitalism and all of that but
it's like-minded people talking to each
other and I think part of the problem is
that those outside rubber we're talking
different languages
that's absolutely right I mean we did
some interesting work at the Bank of
England recently looking at dr. Seuss
and the simplicity of the language in
dr. Seuss we looked at our own
publications and found that you know we
assumed a reading level that was you
know very close to university level when
we say we're trying to reach the wider
public because if we genuinely want to
communicate we need to make sure it's in
language that is available to others the
interesting thing is that the people who
have been able to communicate most
clearly right now are actually the
populism Donald Trump is a
brilliant communicator so perhaps the
regular English would be learning from
dr. Seuss and Donald Trump well I mean I
think I think it's it's a huge challenge
and it was all got to get better at
communicating now having said that I
don't want to imply that you know it's
just about communication because it is
also about the need for policy change
but you're not going to get support for
policy change until you're able to
communicate clearly the news thank you
very much indeed